[Music]
inspired by pen and paper role-playing
games
such as dungeons and dragons the rpg
video game genre
started in the mid-1970s towards the
late 70s and into the early 80s a
sub-genre began to emerge
the action-rpg arpgs still focused
heavily on storyline
quests characters stats and attributes
except rather than being turn
or menu based combat the player had
direct control over the characters in
real time
this added a new layer of challenge to
the user where coordination
and reaction time would now affect the
outcome of each encounter
[Music]
around the same time during the 1970s
another genre of video game began making
its mark in the industry
the shooter using a character
wielding one or more weapons shooters
would test the player's spatial
awareness
reflexes and reaction speed against npcs
or other player controlled characters
for more than two decades these two game
types continue to grow in popularity
games like the legend of zelda the
ultimate underworld series
doom duke nukem 3d quake
diablo goldeneye unreal tournament
we're all exploding across the industry
by the 2000s shooters and arpgs were
hitting a new peak in their stride
shooters like halo call of duty and
gears of war became household names
pushing the limits of both player versus
environment and player versus player
options
arpgs like path of exile diablo 2 and
world of warcraft
further defined the grind pushing the
limits of gameplay including character
classes
random weapons skill trees armor and
chasing the perfect stats and attributes
on all loot that could be found
it was around this time that the kids
who were playing these games in the 80s
and late 90s
entered the video game development
industry adding fresh perspective
this coupled with greater infrastructure
internet speeds and servers capable of
handling far greater numbers
and more complex battles opened up the
world to a new genre of game
that will combine the accuracy and speed
of the shooter with the character
classes
levelling and loop grind of rpgs
hell gate london is a dark fantasy arpg
first person shooter
developed by a team led by former
blizzard entertainment employees
who had previously worked on the diablo
series
set in a post-apocalyptic london in the
year 2038
it included random elements such as
weapon and armor attributes
loot drops and mob spawns
the game had single player and online
multiplayer features
however in a little over a year the
ongoing service support was shut down in
the united states and europe
it was relaunched again in 2011 2014 and
2018.
in 2007 only a month after hellgate was
released an mmo rpg
called taboola rasa was developed by
destination games
taking place in the near future it tells
the story of humanity's last stand
against an alien race called the bane
the gameplay included missions story
character creation
a dynamic battlefield where npc forces
were constantly warring over control
points and bases
and mixed elements from both shooters
and rpgs
it was released during world of
warcraft's peak and was targeted towards
fans of the title
unfortunately much like hellgate the
game never managed to find its audience
and a little over a year later would end
public service
although hellgate and tabula rasa never
found their footing
they managed to secure a path for future
additions to the genre
in 2009 gearbox software released a
first person shooter with rpg elements
called borderlands single-player and
cooperative
borderlands introduced a gritty uniquely
animated gameplay that was inspired by
various action role-playing games at the
time
such as ultima and diablo
playing through missions and side quests
players have access to random items that
can produce to 17 million different
combinations of weapons
attributes including the barrel bullets
scopes materials
and elemental damage they were also able
to access customizable vehicles
there were four character classes that
were available each with their own story
skills and ability that could be leveled
up to progress through the unique skill
trees
focus was placed on the shooter aspect
of the game first with the rpg as a
close second
this combination was well accepted by
the gaming community selling millions of
copies
and stamping the luda shooter on the map
as an upcoming genre in the industry
this led to sequels such as borderlands
2 released in 2012
and borderlands 3 2019
in 2013 digital extremes following the
success of free-to-play games
released warframe set in the distant
future
players take control of members of an
ancient race of warriors who have awoken
from cairo's sleep
they find themselves in a solar system
plagued by war with various factions
playing through mission solo or the
group of up to four players
experiences gained on mission completion
where characters can be levelled up with
better weapons and mods
these mods can be used to change
attributes and add bonuses and abilities
digital extremes free to play model can
be credited towards warframe success
where many games working in the space
have struggled to find balance with pay
to win elements
warframe avoids this by making the same
items available to be acquired
through the gameplay itself players can
choose whether to put the work in and
grind for it or to purchase items if
they want them immediately
[Music]
initially the growth of warframe was
fairly average
mediocre reviews low play accounts and
it take a little while to get off the
ground
however the developers have stuck with
the title and continue to build on the
platform
today warframe is a widely successful
title boasting around 50 million players
from the studio that created the
massively popular halo series
bungie moved on to create a shared world
ludashuda
set 700 years into the future destiny is
the story of the protectors of earth
the guardians using the power of the
light
the guardians defend the last city from
various alien threats
guardians can be one of three classes
each possessing their own set of skills
that are unlocked
as experiences gained destiny introduced
a number of open shared world areas on
the map
where players can team up and take on
different enemy races on different
planets
the gameplay is split between pvp and
pve game modes
true to their roots the pvp offers fast
pace action
similar to what was seen in halo the pve
modes
range from public events to missions
strikes and even raids for teams of six
players
initially destiny was a highly
anticipated and well-received title
but over time gained criticism for its
repetitive gameplay loop
but a series of dlcs brought the game
back on track
in 2017 destiny 2 was released
again there was a huge amount of hype
from the community but shortly after
critics and hardcore fans of the
franchise labelled the game as shallow
and many of the elements that made
disney great were stripped out to cater
for the casual player
a year later the majority of these
elements were reintroduced
inherited from their time with halo
destiny brings fine-tuned gunplay
a rich story in a distinct sci-fi
setting
bungie played to their strengths
focusing on the shooter elements first
and the rng loot and build diversity
second
this has proved to be a winning
combination as destiny and disney 2
have been upon the most successful games
in the loot of shooter genre to date
in 2016 massive entertainment dipped
their hand into the pool
and released a more realistic
military-style looter shooter
tom clancy's the division
with a darker theme than most of the
other games in the genre it is set in a
morally complicated near future
that features elite sleeper sales of
agents who are trying to maintain order
in a post-pandemic
apocalyptic new york city the majority
of the gameplay is split into two
sections
pvp and pve with the third section of
the map
where the two cross over this area is
known as the dark zone
a player versus environment versus
player area
this would lead the player to choose
what to do help fellow agents in the
fight
or turn on them stealing their loot
much like other looter shooters players
are set forth to level up their
character through missions and open
world activities
and collect weapons and armor to upgrade
their agent
the division is a third world cover
shooter with gunplay feeling a little
more realistic than other titles
however much like that of other games in
this space criticism around the endgame
and lack of gameplay loop became an
issue but also because of the heavy
focus on loot and build diversity
the developers have struggled with
balancing issues from day one
in 2019 the division 2 was released
it was praised by many calling it the
new bar that others should aim for
in the ludashuter genre however this was
quickly forgotten
as familiar complaints regarding the end
game and lack of content began to
surface
regardless both games broke sales
records upon release
and have continued to be updated with
new content over time
[Music]
in 2019 bioware stepped into the looter
shooter arena with anthem
[Music]
with past titles like star wars knights
of the old republic
mass effect and dragon age the community
had high hopes for this title
players would take on the role of a
freelancer who wear powerful exo suits
to defend humanity from the threats that
lie beyond the city walls
a third person shooter with rpg elements
anthem provides an open world experience
and different classes to level up and
specialize into
a purely pve game players can run
missions in open world activities either
solo
or with a team of up to four anthem
excelled in filling the power fantasy of
the player
through being able to take to the skies
flying through ravines waterfalls and
even underwater
weapons and special abilities feel
powerful placing the user in a position
of feeling like a superhero among
hostile forces
a huge marketing push further built the
hype around this title leading up to
release day
but as the genre is shown time and time
again anthem fell short of user
expectations
it was criticized for its grind lack of
end game and story
contributing to an experience that felt
shallow and repetitive
the game failed to meet commercial
expectations
bioware has recently confirmed that they
will be reinventing the core gameplay of
anthem
as part of a long-term plan and it will
continue to be supported
the ludas shooter genre is in its
infantile stages
as more developers explore this area of
the industry we're likely to see many
more directions and initiatives in the
space
this is only the beginning where
traditional games offer a linear path
through the story
lunar shooters are more open allowing
the player to forge their own path
further assisting the user to fully
immerse into the storytelling and rich
lore
more often than not they are always
online live service games
this obviously comes with a number of
drawbacks but it also offers an
ever-changing landscape
where players can pop in and out of
games leading to more opportunities for
random moments to occur
it means that these games often don't
really end stories
new missions map extensions are forever
being added
lunar shooters often allow the player to
get creative with the characters
both in a vanity perspective and through
their loadouts with hundreds
thousands or even millions of possible
combinations players can theory craft
and spend many hours chasing down that
last perfect piece
looter shooters require a different way
of thinking where shooters require map
knowledge
reaction speed spatial awareness looter
shooters add to this by requiring the
user to plan and strategize loadouts and
gear pieces
and encounters as found in rpgs
the time spent looking through the loot
and tweaking builds would easily match
the time spent running encounters
[Music]
however with all of these positives the
genre also seems to be plagued with a
number of recurring issues
they almost always seem to release with
development problems this leads to
months of patches and bug fixing that
hinders the speed at which new content
is released
hungry players quickly work through the
content often in days
leading to a long wait between dlcs and
updates
these weights then start to have an
effect on player numbers a lot of the
time never returning to their original
heights
another aspect of looter shooters that
could be challenging for developers
is that they often aren't competitive
enough for players who prefer shooters
yet not deep enough for rpgs
this leads to a split in the community
pvp versus pve
each wanting more content in their
preferred areas
when companies announce their product
they have the greatest division
but more often than not they are heavily
underestimating the community's ability
to eat up content
having them fall into the far too
familiar trend of lacking in-game
with a poorly polished gameplay loop
there are certainly pros and cons to the
luda shooter but it's still very much in
its early stages in the gaming industry
so over time we're likely to see changes
that will correct some of the repeated
concerns that each game has brought so
far
more and more developers seem to be
exploring the potential to take the
basic formula in new directions
in saying that titles like destiny the
division and warframe
don't seem to be going anywhere and have
solidly stamped their place in the
industry
as developers continue to balance and
then rebalance while also pushing out
new content
lunar shooters are huge offering great
depth with their constantly evolving
worlds and deep story
where looter shooters or even pc gaming
will be in the next 10 years as anyone's
guess
but there is a pretty good chance that
we'll still be organizing raids tweaking
builds
farming for that perfect piece and then
screaming about it until it gets nerfed
into oblivion
you